Epigenetics is the study of changes
in gene function that are heritable
and that are not attributed to
alterations of the DNA sequence.
Epigenetics can cause changes in gene expression
but that are not changes in the DNA sequence.
These mechanisms include DNA methylation,
histone modification, and non-coding
RNA such as micro RNAs and the effect of
non-coding repeating regions in the DNA code.
Before we go into the specifics of
epigenetic variation or regulation,
let's discuss the structure of DNA and
how it is organized in eukaryotic cells.
As you remember, the foundational understanding
about phenotypes is that DNA codes for genes,
those genes are transcribed into mRNA which are
then translated into proteins. However, these
processes appear to be regulated by a variety of
mechanisms that are not directly recorded in the
actual code of DNA. In fact, individuals and
members of different species can have similar
DNA like twins or many conserved genes like humans
and monkeys, but significant phenotypic variation
can be easily observed that is the result of
epigenetic changes that are either established
and passed through generations, or acquired
and lost throughout the organisms lifetime.
The eukaryotic cell has a nucleus that contains
tightly packaged DNA folded into structures that
we all know as chromosomes. These are packaged
together by the way of chromatin protein complexes
that the DNA is wrapped around. On these images,
you can see how the DNA string has more bumps
or beads. These visible beads are called histones.
When these beads were originally discovered,
scientists first confused them with genes until
eventually it was proven that the string-like
structures actually contained the genetic
code. Histones can be either grouped together
forming lumps of DNA, or as we can see in the
picture on the right, relaxed and spread out.
The changes in the way DNA is packaged is used
for cell division when whole chromosomes need
to be moved around or to regulate what code
is more or less accessible for transcription.
The regulation of DNA compactness is regulated
in several ways. One of these is DNA methylation.
Cytosine is one of the nucleotide that
can be modified by a methyl group,
CH3, catalyzed by a specialized enzyme called DNA
methyl transferase. In the first minutes of life,
when we are composed of a single cell and this
epigenetic information has been wiped clean in
the fertilized egg. The methyl groups have been
removed and every gene is like all the others.
Through the process of cell differentiation,
DNA methyl transferases add methyl groups
to genes shutting off some, in activating
others. When a cell divides, the epigenetic
information must be transmitted to each of the
new cells by a different DNA methyl transferase,
called DNMT1. DNMT1 adds the proper methyl
groups to these DNA strands as it is replicated.
The information is propagated in a tricky
way. The methyl groups almost always added
to cytosine bases with these sequences, CG and
GC. Notice that both strands have a cytosine. So,
in a methylated region of DNA, both strands will
have a methyl group when the DNA is replicated.
Each of the new DNA double helices will have
one old strand, complete with methyl groups,
and one new strand which is not methylated. So
DNMT1 just needs to look for the CG bases sites,
where only one strand has a methyl group.
The basic repeating unit of chromatin is
the nucleosome, in which hundred and forty-six
base pairs of DNA wraps around an octamer of core
histones consisting of pairs of H3, H4, H2A, and
H2B. The terminal tails of histones protrude out
of the nucleosome and are subject to a variety
of post translational modifications, such as
acetylation, phosphorylation, ubiquitination,
and lysine and arginine methylation.
Acetylation was the first of these modifications
to be linked with active transcription.
Subsequently, phosphorylation of histone
H3 was found to cooperate with a situation
in translational activation. Some histone
methylation events have also been associated
with transcription activation, and others with
gene silencing. One important aspect of histones
is that they can be changed to alter how
much packing the DNA is capable of. There are
several modifications that affect how well DNA is
packaged. The basic regulation is done via groups
of atoms that are at the ends of histones. These
can be of several types and will have a positive
or a negative charge that either attract them
together or force them apart. The DNA region that
is wrapped around the histones can be more or less
accessible causing variation in gene expression.
Histone proteins or nucleosomes undergo a host
of different post translational modifications
including phosphorylation, acetylation, and
methylation, which have profound effects on the
remodeling of chromatin. Histone modifications can
function either individually or combinatorially
to govern such processes as transcription,
replication, DNA repair and apoptosis. The
methyl groups of atoms increased packing. Acetyl
group decreases packing. Phosphoryl group can be
attached to the histones and cause a decrease
in packing. These groups of atoms are attached
to various types of histones at various locations.
As the DNA is wrapped around the histones and can
be more or less accessible, various
positions of the DNA are affected.
These include the promoter region, transcription
start sites, and the introns and exons of genes.
Each one of these elements can have a significant
effect on the level of gene expression,
on alternative splicing, as well as
other downstream regulation of pathways.